you must cut negativity out of your life
whether that is your mother and I don't
mean never talk to her again but maybe
you don't need to talk to your mom four
times a day or she's complaining four
times a day maybe it could be once every
two days this is why the news is a
disaster for most people all it's going
to do is scare you and make you unhappy
like you need to start cutting
negativity out and you need to start
bringing positivity in you might have a
co-worker who's just genuinely a gleeful
person and you kind of know them what
about asking them out for lunch what
about becoming a friend with that
cutting negativity adding positivity is
how you get out of rust